[Music]
for all of its twitchy and
fast-paced action cs go can be an
absurdly
tense and tactical esport whether you're
orchestrating meticulous airtight
executes
these grenades could do all of the work
for them
three of them going over the wall one on
exist one on crims
everybody's catching fire twist goes
down and there it is
they close it right out or suka blyating
there's usually a method to your madness
maybe you're capitalizing on a
positional weakness or pressing an
economic
advantage maybe you're just sending it
or maybe you're injecting the game with
some much needed spice
they're ready to shoot some ducks as
they cross the middle it's going to be a
challenge and
apex not in this lifetime
he is destroyed whatever you do
there should be some element of strategy
behind it because for that minute and 55
seconds
there are no second chances no respawns
no respite
your movement needs to be precise your
shots
crisp what no
i have no words one millimeter too far
one step too soon and it's over so when
the pressure's on
and you need to secure that frag the
last thing you want to do is
run in and die like an idiot you want to
play with respect
and a certain degree of reservation oh
he's read this one like a book he's
tucked in the corner
does he catch the timing can't afford to
look away and that's the round for zip
nicks
unless of course you're the one dude in
cs go who no matter
how stupid or suicidal the maneuver
is just well better
it's time for regret later it's time to
focus on the now are creeping with awp
has he got time to fall back will he be
traded north don't know what lies in
these toilets especially three you've
got to respect them
but yuri will get taken out they know
that odd still there somewhere not
baited just yet and that's the bomb once
again
way more can he get he's stuck in this
position gate is waiting for him to
emerge from the other side
this is looking pretty grim here our
force ball is with it oh he hits another
one that is fantastic
drops out for the ak-47 you can't ask
for any more from artis
an absolute superstar meet andre
art pio vezan a badass brazilian
up-and-comer who
skyrocketed his way into the upper
echelon of counter-strike
by doing one thing and one thing only
holding w not really anything to write
home about but there's that down towards
b
taco gets his face removed and now k and
g are having to rotate around from the a
site
that's trying to close the gap i'll try
to get in their face so he's gonna roast
falling in the molotov gives for the oh
there's a lot of molly's there how's he
still alive how is he still alive three
points of health he runs through the
double molotov and lives to tell the
story
kng this man is invincible
oh my word touted as being the single
most aggressive player his game has
ever seen art has developed an obsession
with entry fragging
like a psychopath so art is the madman
he's the man with the brush that's kind
of turning the aggressive style of
counter-strike upside down once more you
remember when jw and fur and all those
guys were mad men
well art is like that times 10. so what
inspired arch to become cs go's
ultimate w warrior in what sense are his
strats
actually super big brained and how has
his
unhindered aggression revived a
floundering region
it's also like an exciting rebuilding
team for mibr you know to finally give
us the team that we wanted but look at
oh man
he's stealing the attention right now
even with the hughes news breaking
oh he's just breaking down team liquid
he's still running
and he's in with a fourth my goodness oh
[Music]
okay so if you're even remotely
interested in counter strike and you've
yet to take a second to welcome our
lord and savior art into your life it's
time that you learned about this
magnificent
sight rushing son of a [ __ ] art is the
entry fragger
in-game leader and all-around front man
of fury
esports brazilian counter-strike's
latest breakout success
he's also largely credited with being
the mastermind behind their recent
rise to the top why well in order to
answer
that we need to rewind a little bit you
see unlike a lot of csgo aficionados art
wasn't
dyed in the wool of 1.6 don't get me
wrong
he dabbled in the original
counter-strike but like a lot of edgy
strategy-obsessed e-gamers
art cut his teeth on the playgrounds of
team fortress 2
and because he's a beauty dota 2 but in
2016
that all changed when a friend
introduced him to cs go
and from that point on art was obsessed
now that was only four years ago so some
really simple math tells us that art got
really good at cs really fast how
why by playing fast i kind of
just took the experience ahead in
tibetan shoe
and something like a mental game like in
dota
and i have been playing games all my
life so i just kind of feel like i was
playing counter strike it was impressive
intuitive to me
i don't think it was like hard to learn
a game and
maybe maybe the way i play like uh
too aggressive and doing active stuff
all the time i think that
that makes you learn the game faster
because all the time i'm playing i'm
doing
stuff and thinking about the game i'm
actively rotating the map and thinking
all the time because if i don't think i
died
so how did art go from the smoke pushing
silver who was
merely experimenting with his w key to
the freight train that he is today
well the better he got at cs the more he
began to realize that there's something
kind of inherently big-brained about
playing with
unhindered aggression where others saw
brain-dead rat strats and nonsensical
[ __ ] that people would do only in
pugs
art saw an opportunity to innovate i got
a lot of threats just out of bugs simple
as that i was just playing
like fpl or just playing matchmaking and
i see some players doing some
you could say dumb stuff for me it's
smart stuff because when they're
catching off guard
and just putting yourself in a bad
position they are actually being smart
they're just making plays on fbl but
they don't play like that on the game
and that always bothers me if they play
like that on the
official games they will actually
play better it's gonna work uh so
this is like a plug life uh way of
playing and that works you know it's
like a street smart it's very smart
see that's the thing about
counter-strike it's so brutal
and so unforgiving that oftentimes one's
natural
instinct is to take things slow and
steady
but that's not always a good thing i
mean we've all watched silvers try to
slow walk their way to a
thunderous t-side come on little fella
come on
come on little oh my god i'll just go
anyway before art could put his
philosophy to the test he'd need an
org to supply him with a roster of
like-minded ruffians
masochists who were both stupid and
crazy enough to build an entire team
around not only holding w but gluing it
to their goddamn keyboards
and that's how he ended up on furia
under art's direction fury emerged from
2018
as not only brazil's best up-and-coming
roster
but a literal band of brothers while
they were still
minor blips on most people's radars that
all changed in 2019
when a teammate brought something to
art's attention
a crazily overpowered yet woefully
underutilized weapon the krieg
keeping ants's dreams alive here
they lose this map they are done for art
he's gonna barrage with the sg it's
gonna be two kills on the third
that [ __ ] across the aerial four people
here with next are on the other side
they don't have a lot of grenades on g2
here but when they go it's gonna be fast
then oh they just line up for an
art with a big triple all of them head
shots needs to connect that headshot
perhaps
finally yuki gets into the action but
another hedgehog coming out from odd
he's doing some massive damage here
looking for the quad kill
as there's a player on the ball he's
going to stick it here oh he actually
comes off of it
oh house managed to put it off they
haven't given anything away for art in
the meantime
of course he snuck it up connector and
just strictly one sided sergey and gonna
find ariel as well again it's art
we make funny jokes because if he if he
knew that kiriga has
uh that stroke before we could
we could have been like a major winners
way before
because we just too strongly we don't
even knew it
and we just kind of kind of blaming
vinnie for not telling us that this game
was so strong needless to say
it wasn't long before more established
teams took
notice of furious discovery which would
go on to become
meta-defining the krieg enabled art to
do what he'd
always dreamed of build a roster that
played
unthinkably aggressive counter-strike
one that eschewed
careful and methodical executes in favor
of
well going
most teams are just doing like those
normal
uh play styles they just kind of hold us
this side
and they try to do easex and fakes or
double fakes
and that was just kind of the meta of cs
and on brazil
the teams are not so strong on doing
those things as european teams or
any teams so my thought process was just
like okay guys
we have a good team we have good players
we have good aim we can just play
as simple as possible and as aggressive
as possible so you can punish them and
don't let them play
we are better than them like this and if
you just surprise them they don't have a
game to play
four on four art could come right over
the top he's hoping to catch him look at
the wrong way he gets
them lined up triple spray for heart a
nearly gets a quad
thanks in large part to their pioneering
of the krieg meta
furio had finally found an avenue to go
global
over the course of 2019 art put his
roster
on the map helping them qualify for a
slew of international tournaments
including both the katowice and berlin
majors
i feel like this man only has a w key
and an inability to look away from his
opponents
and we i kind of just kept believing it
was just good enough for
everything because i as a player i
always watch
a professional construct since then i
was watching and i just
looking at the game and i can see that
the things i i want to do
they're going to work as well against
those teams and nobody's doing it
are they brave enough to go through that
smoke our picks the right direction he's
surrounded by two more players that's a
huge headshot from him
sees a trajectory he knows where device
is looking to cap him almost but not
quite
smokes up they don't have to worry about
bomb plant pressure just yet there's a
minute on the clock
with the glock he'll get another kill
and all the while he led
by example cementing himself as an
unreasonably aggressive in-game leader
oh what why is he jumped
and why has it worked i see these people
rage about me from like
three years back then people are just
complaining about me and
say i suck and even so they say i ain't
so bad
they still don't want to face me because
it's just too annoying
i know that because when i play
matchmaking i hate these guys that just
play like
[ __ ] you know they're just pushing
smoke they're just throwing molotovs and
going through it
and you hate those guys it's time for
regret later it's time to focus on them
now
our three figures awp has he got time to
fall back will he be traded
north don't know what lies in these
toilets especially three you've got to
respect them
but yuri will get taken out he know that
odd still there somewhere not baited
just yet and that's the bomb once again
why more can he get he's stuck in this
position gate is waiting for him to
emerge from the other side
this is looking pretty grim here our
force ball is with it
another one that is fantastic swaps out
for the ak-47
you can't ask for any more from artis an
absolute superstar
and then shortly into 2020 the krieg was
slapped with a
much needed nerf and right as the
community was beginning to wonder
whether
that would stifle furia art did
something that
felt kind of impossible
he went even more ham is an overhead
winner loss
but an opening up kill oh my god with
the quickness our comes through and the
deagle to combine
these guys are working together like
peanut butter and jelly
[Music]
for the run which hasn't quite worked
out but at least baits the shot and
gains the angle
made into the perfect spot johnny wants
to go through and oh he's a madman
survives and oh again p250 pulled out
but art manages to single-handedly
open up that b sight bomb is gonna be
thrown across for now as we see the
consistent aggression with a third and
he's hungry for more
but up against steel
oh i don't even know what to say about
that that was insane
cts will however have another buy it
it's not the end of the world just
yet but this is again just art doing art
things
aggression into mid a quick head shot
onto moose he's even gonna go
jumping into the windows but be careful
with me waiting on the other side but of
course art wins that battle as well
can nifty trading no he can't art is on
an absolute tear
leaving just two players standing and
what just ace it come on just clear them
all out
there's only one man left in your way
and art's gonna do the job
all on his own over the course of 2020
art's w holding
went off the richter scale his unmatched
aggression
even inspired a youtuber by the name of
hakka
to put it into perspective this graph
shows every player's t-side opening kill
stats from 2015
through to 2020. the left axis shows how
successful a player is in opening fights
while the bottom axis shows how often
they attempt to get the opening kill
every single one of these dots displays
an entire year of a player's career
with the players at the top of the graph
having the highest success rate and the
players at the furthest right of the
graph
being the most aggressive and you can
see there are a few outliers but mostly
everyone fits into roughly the same area
everyone except the one man i haven't
shown on this graph so far
brace yourselves and there he is
it was as if someone took stewie jw and
a silver 3
slapped them together injected them with
g-fuel
and prefaced every round by saying who
cares
it's last round go for it
pretending colin's good enough to be a
silver three
classic art is the madman he's the man
with the brush that's kind of turning
the aggressive style of counter-strike
upside down once more you remember when
jw and fur and all those guys were mad
men
well art is like that times 10. the
crazy thing
is that the more aggressive furia became
the better they got you see in addition
to finishing in the top
four of esl one cologne north america
and winning the north american divisions
of dreamhack masters spring
and esl pro league season 12 fury have
solidified themselves
as one of the five best rosters in the
world
dude they have no idea they're gonna
come down the ladder in front of him
he's he's gone he's gonna he's right
there yeah
there's a player that's cool like he's
gonna get that kill it's done
it's done nitro he's tapped down art
finishes the round
and we crown our champions dreamhack
masters spring 2020 belongs
to furious thanks to their fearless
leader
and the truly artisanal ass whoopings
he's dished out
fyria are well on their way to being a
household name
cementing themselves as a terror on the
server
so how is it that art manages to be this
unremittingly nutty to hold down his w
key in even
the most high pressure of situations
well
as it so happens i'm a bit of an
aspiring w warrior myself
so as someone who pretty much worships
the ground on which art walks
i had to ask him so i did
i have to say i really don't care like
i just don't mind if uh this loses the
game
or that wins the game i just think that
i'm doing the right thing
i and i don't doubt myself and i trust
my my knowledge of the play i'm doing
like
if i'm doing something aggressive i
trust that that thing is good
it isn't clear exactly what the future
holds for art and his acolytes
but whatever happens one thing is for
sure
these dudes are bringing back brazilian
counter-strike
in a big way and they're beyond excited
about it
but regardless of nationality furia are
amassing fans across the globe
for their bold balls to the wall
playstyle
art hasn't just proven himself as a
force to be reckoned with
he's inspiring the entire counter-strike
community to
speed things up a bit and god knows
if there's any hope of us keeping up
with him
we're gonna need to for me it's just
huge how many people
uh are looking up for us uh
and i don't know if he happens to be
that we are the next team that brazil
uh takes you to to love or just hate
uh the love to be in that spot it is
going to happen it's gonna be a natural
process and it's up to our results if we
keep playing good then we can play
major finals catch playoffs majors win a
major you're thinking about the game
if we play well and we deserve it it's
gonna happen so just the usps coming
through
oh he's already in b absolutely he's
right there though he's walking all the
way through he's walking all the way
through
oh they've put smokes in just for him to
make a wall run all that way through
that's such a cool strat what on earth
that is so cool
that's so bizarre so you know this meme
right how do you think i should
pronounce it like
burr or bro like going burr
burr